earlier which I'm glad this question
came up and she was like you know a lot
of girls will get into this industry and
whining them playing why is someone
taking me seriously why does someone
want to marry me bro I knew that from
the beginning I only really started
seriously dating the moment I was like I
can't say so I started out in porn it's
a little different it's definitely more
intense the kind of hate you get only
fans of me is I've seen it be more
accepted but being in mainstream porn
where you open a PornHub and you're on
the ads I didn't bother I did not even
bother there's no way because I knew I'm
not saying I knew I was low value or
whatever you guys like to say high value
low value but I knew that like my dating
was gonna be harder but I feel like a
lot of people and only fans are so damn
delusional being like well I am I am a
traditional woman I am a high value no
we're not sorry